hey guys it's Justine and today we're
checking out the insta 360 go look at
this thing it is so tiny
I love into 360 and I love their
products I love their cameras and love
their software so I'm so excited to
check this out I haven't even opened it
yet and I'm so excited like this guy's
got a click on his shirt I love
portability I love small compact cameras
anything that makes my traveling lighter
is something that I'm into you plug it
right into your phone let's hope that
Apple doesn't change to USB see all
right I hope that they do that's gonna
pose a problem for a lot of accessories
Oh stickers Oh more accessories he's
just looking different types of mouse
there's so much stuff crammed in this
little box this looks like a little
sticky mounts and it also says on the
back to keep it so you can reapply it
there's another little mouth and this
one is really cool it looks like you can
just move this around just like a little
tripod attachment so you can attach that
to here and these are all just magnetic
and here is the camera let's open it up
look how small this is I can't believe
it this is just so crazy it just
magnetically attaches to like everything
this is so great are you seeing this
this is gonna be so much fun I cannot
wait so now I want to attach it to my
shirt oh how cool I am I can't wait to
go out and use this
[Music]
[Applause]
so have the app old downloaded so you
just plug it in and it will
automatically start importing all of
your photos and videos for you so this
is the action button right here so when
the camera is off it is set to do a
little quick capture so I haven't set to
do videos if I press it this is right
now recording a video and a report for
30 seconds and this is me recording the
video this is so crazy but this is a
camera so inside the app you can set
this action button to do multiple things
and it's great because you could edit
all of these settings inside of the app
or you can also connect it to Bluetooth
and let's see my picture that I took I
mean can you say profile pic yeah for
sure so you go into the settings here's
the camera button settings so this will
show you when the camera is off and you
click the quick capture this will shoot
standard video so you can change it if
you want 15 seconds or 30 seconds of
length so that's the answer 30 60 go I
am so excited about this camera mostly
just because I think it's gonna be great
for getting shots that you normally
wouldn't ever be able to get because
this camera is so small and compact that
you can put it in mounted places that
you never cooked before and now let's
take this out and get some cool shots
with it 3,000 miles from home trying to
say and I will get there soon
Bertie they sigh walk down this way
singing my madness to the moon
I'm a de quatre on the tree
and it taught to me about things we
don't see
I asked it how do I know which is the
right way to go and just like that my
sister and I are in Hawaii I'm so
excited to test this thing out here I've
been using this for the past couple of
days and the first thing that I've
noticed is this is unlike any other
camera that I've ever tested because it
shoots in 15 to 30 second increments you
have to be thinking completely
differently when you're filming I'm just
gonna go ahead and say that one of my
highlights though was I dropped this
other side of the mountain and this hike
was extremely dangerous so having this
was great because I was completely
hands-free unless I knew that I was
comfortable enough to be able to use it
but it was great because I could just
attach it here shoot for 30 seconds get
really cool hyper LAX's photos always
right here and easily accessible it's
just like this my only fear is pretty
tight connection good like we're
climbing up rocks
[Music]
your camera oh my god that was my
biggest fear I can get it are you sure
yeah
challenge accepted
[Music]
yeah
Oh No your camera challenge accepted
woman oh my god I told you I know I know
hold on it already was that I was gonna
drop the insert there sixty one camera
and guess what I did
now Jenna's on a rescue mission rescue
to save it be careful who they wear
GoPros on their head oh my gosh okay oh
this is incredible I can't believe what
just happened
but I do believe it I'm sweating so much
so what was it - oxy I saw it I saw it
tunnel the one thing that has taken a
little bit of getting used to is the
fact that you get haptic feedback and
that's how you know what's happening
because there's no screens on here there
is a tiny little light so that will also
give you some indication of what's
happening but it's flashing faster
that's shooting a hyperlapse when it's
flashing consistently slower let
shooting a video but this thing it's
kind of a novelty camera obviously it's
not something that you can consistently
vlog on it's really easy to import the
footage and I love that it'll
automatically import all of the footage
so unlike the insta 360 one where you
have to go in and select the different
clips that you want to import this will
automatically import everything it'll
also delete all the footage right from
the camera so there's no SD cards
there's nothing it's all internal memory
and once you get past the small learning
curve of how this actually works it's
pretty freakin awesome
also water resistant which is great
because on this hike that we did I was
sweating profusely we've also had it
here at the beach we've had it around
the pool of the house that we're staying
at and it's just a fun little camera
what I'm most excited about is the
future iterations of this if this is
where we're at right now
I can only imagine the things that
they're working on in the future one of
the good things is this camera is
water-resistant so it makes it great for
go to beach going to the pool there's a
turtle
some of the footage that you shoot on it
is better than other footage I love this
little AI editing that they have you can
create automated little stories and
using AI it tries to determine which
scenes are the best to use out of each
clip it'll automatically make you little
tiny stories and it was really fun to
try out because I've shot so much stuff
on this already that it just
automatically took everything that I
filmed and made me this
[Music]
that's a good first look at the Institut
six ago
thank you guys so much for watching I
look forward to sharing some of the
stuff on social so if you guys are
following me on Twitter or Instagram
make sure you go check it out there
because I'll posting some of the things
that I didn't post here on this after
I've already edited in close of this
video
[Music]
running tired
Chetta yelled at me for climbing up this
tree but now I'm curious what looks like
if I climb up it with these operations
to go
[Music]
ready
[Applause]
okay so we did that
Jenna hates it well look how close this
tree branches to falling
[Music]